well i feel like a bird that wants to
fly away actually getting the first one
was really an amazing thing to me and i
thought just to be in the guinness book
of world records one time would be great
and now that i've got all this going
it's just like an amazing feeling i'm
very honored very proud and i've had a
lot of people helping me get to here so
thanks to all of you and to all of them
for helping me have all this
nobody ever knows when you're starting
out how how you're going to do but
i used to think though about midlife i
used to think how am i going to feel
when i'm older looking back on my career
and this is the kind of stuff that
really makes you very humble and makes
you very thankful and grateful
[Music]
well i could it could because i'm older
than music
and i have just kind of never let up
i've just always tried to stay relevant
i always try to not follow trends or
anything but stay in the know
and to kind of be involved and i'll
write songs so many of the people that
are following my career now that say
that i have been
an inspiration are usually young women
that really are looking at how i have
run my life and my business so that's
been an inspiration that makes me proud
and then a lot of them just like the
songs i've written which that really
makes me proud because i'm i take myself
more serious as a songwriter than
anything else and to know that all these
younger people this young generation are
still finding my songs and loving them
and still treating me with great respect
thinking that i'm still important that's
also a very humbling
feeling well i just want to say that i
have had a wonderful time in this
business over six decades i started very
young my first record was when i was
about 10 or 11 years old
and so i don't guess that one counts and
this batch of stuff so you might have to
give me another award i don't know but
i've just i've just loved being able to
make a living in the business that i
love so much and i've just been so
fortunate to see my dreams come true and
i just hope to continue for as long as i
can you're gonna have to knock me down
to stop me